[Music]  fundamentally there's a lot of state  because they're trying to answer  something really big  how'd the universe begin did time begin  with the Big Bang and after the universe  began it then went through a really  rapid period of expansion called  inflation  another possibility is the universe  didn't begin with the Big Bang but  rather has gone through a cycle of  collapse and then re expansion those are  two very different theories how the  universe began what we're going after is  to try to distinguish between those two  theories  [Music]  well I'm very excited about it we were  supposed to see first light in three  years I think I can't wait I am certain  that very good science is going to come  out of it one way or the other  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you